plus de 1700 m² une salle de sport une
salle de spectacle un espace
informatique la nouvelle maison de
l'étudiant de l'université versailles
saint quentin réunis sur un même lieu
l'ensemble des services dédiés aux
étudiants
objectif leur simplifier la vie il ya le
service logement
le service d aide à l'handicap pour les
étudiants en situation de handicap et
donc il faut voir cette maison comme
vraiment un lieu où tous les services de
la vie universitaire pour les étudiants
sont regroupés ce qui nous permet nous
un meilleur affichage et
une meilleure intégration de nos
étudiants dès qu'ils s'inscrivent en
tout l'ensemble des services s'étale sur
trois niveaux et peuvent abriter
notamment les 32 associations étudiantes
de l'ue vs q reste désormais aux
dix-huit mille concernés à faire vivre
les lieux tout au long de l'année
bien sûr elle existe elle est là et on
est très content il faut que les
étudiants s'y investissent créent des
événements dans cette dans cette maison
de l'étudiant face des demandes de
matériel pour équiper la salle de
théâtre en fonction de leurs besoins
une phase des demandes concernant aussi
les cafétérias en fonction de seconde
qui veulent en bref c'est plus
maintenant de l'accessoire au quotidien
que vraiment les fondements les
fondements sont là et on est très
content d avoir dévoilé également le nom
du bâtiment martha panne référence et
une sculptrice hongroise connu du
territoire en cherchant et bien
évidemment ça m'est apparu assez
rapidement une évidence que ça pourrait
être martha panne qui a donc une
sculpture dans les sources de la bièvre
et qui dans les années 80-90 a été
c'était vraiment une artiste spécialisé
dans l'art urbain et qui a conseillé
les ministres de la culture pour la
construction d'oeuvre au sein des villes
coût de la maison de l'étudiant martha
panne plus de 8 millions d'euros financé
entièrement par la région ile de france